[Music]
hi everyone sal khan here if you look at
most of human history the top artists
the top musicians were also
mathematicians and also scientists and
also engineers
and this convergence between creativity
and mathematics and science and
engineering is only accelerating in the
careers of the future algebra and
creativity are going to be that much
more empowering but don't take my word
for it you're about to meet some of my
close friends who can better draw that
link between algebra and creativity and
work of the future
[Music]
the math underpins everything in our
universe so it impacts every corner of
our society
but over the past decade in particular
the advances in computer technology and
introduction of machine learning and
artificial intelligence has been massive
and we're only learning more and more
and building better and better systems
and matt underpins all of that and it's
fundamental to all of those systems and
in fact computer science is inherently
linear algebra so it's really
foundational to those scientific
advances one relatively recent example
that really inspired me was the first
real photo that scientists were able to
capture of a black hole
this mysterious remnants of giant stars
that lurk all over the universe and it
is the way the scientists used
creativity and math to solve the problem
that was so fascinating you see these
black holes are so distant that there's
no single telescope that is large enough
to be able to actually see them
and the scientists came up with this
clever idea creating a network of small
telescopes distributed all across the
globe that were synchronized to capture
and focus
the same object at the same time
creating a giant virtual telescope now
the aperture of this giant virtual
telescope is nearly the size same size
as the diameter of the earth
and with that in place the scientists
and engineers were able to capture all
the bits and pieces of data and put it
all together into the first image of a
black hole that is 53 million light
years which is
318 quintillion miles away now that's an
impressive use of creativity and mass
[Music]
in the future in order to add innovation
students are going to need skills such
as creative problem solving
so not looking at things from the same
perspective
being able to ideate so come up with new
ideas and divergent thinking right the
ability to come up with ideas that are
drastically different from from each
other beyond creative problem solving
students will also need to be a show
adaptability so the ability to pivot as
the world and constraints around us kind
of pivot
the stem field is constantly evolving
and it's growing as we gain more
knowledge so students ability to be
creative and adapt as the field adapts
will be critical for success and for the
ability to innovate as we move forward
communication skills are always going to
be essential for furthering innovation
and this is because if you want to make
a scientific advancement you have to
have a lot of people on your side so you
have to have funding bodies you have to
have other scientists you have to have
people interested in what you're doing
so this means you have to have the
communication tools to communicate with
all of those different areas of people
so different ways that you can learn to
communicate with them are through things
like presentations through visual aids
through videos when you're preparing for
communication tools of the future it's
quite difficult to know what those will
be so if we think back to 10 years ago
we didn't have things like tick tock
which is not a huge avenue for
communicating things to young people so
that is something that we've had to
adapt to and to learn and tailor our
communication down this
new area of media
so having versatility if students are
able to take their skills that they have
and apply them to new areas of
communication they'll be prepared for
the communication tools of the future
there are so many ways that you can
expand your creative and math skills
without even really realizing that
you're doing it like for me i'm a big
board game fan um and i realized that
there's so many games that involve um
math and learning how to uh solve
problems and
sometimes like just uh when you're
cooking i love to bake and so i feel
like i'm constantly using like fractions
and learning how to do proportions um
just because i'm doing things that i
love so i feel like the best way to
expand your your mathematical and
creative skills are just doing what you
love to do because probably it has
some kind of math in it and
some kind of creativity try to connect
what you're learning to your real life
it's really easy to be in the classroom
and think that it's siloed
and it's orthogonal from the world
around you um the more we can connect
what we're learning in the classroom to
our real life either via sports or
entertainment
politics news whatever
the connection that you make between
math and your real life will really help
you appreciate the skills
and the methods and find ways to
transfer them outside of just the
classroom alone
[Music]
one of the newest
ways of thinking about problem solving
for me
is um something that my math professor
would tell me um he would say
don't be afraid to be stuck
and i think that a lot of the time when
we are doing math and we get stuck it's
like
sometimes it can be you can feel like
wow this is a reflection of me and my
mathematical abilities wow maybe i
shouldn't be doing math
but really a lot of the time it's just
an indication that you need to spend
more time uh doing the math or figuring
out what the problem is exactly if you
haven't gotten stuck yet then i mean you
probably will get stuck at some point so
being stuck is just a part of math and
it's kind of learning how to what to do
when you are stuck is a really big uh
a big part of being creative in math and
being able to um solve homes in the
future one example
that i often use um is
i often try to solve problems um
both in like the traditional um
uh algebraic way but i also um try to
visualize problems um in 2d and 3d space
to solve them more visually and so i
think um
the more ways that you can figure out
how to solve a problem um the more ways
that you can eventually sort of like
save in your toolbox and use
later on to solve other problems there's
lots of different tools and resources
like apps and puzzle games that are
going to help you think about problems
in new ways and help develop that
critical thinking that you need to be
able to apply your skills to a lot of
different areas
and sometimes even starting at the
answer and working backwards through the
problem can help you see a different way
of getting to the answer
students can combine new ways of
thinking about problem solving by trying
to look at it from different angles
anytime you approach a problem if you're
just looking at it from your perspective
you're not going to get a holistic view
of the solution space so try to have
perspectives and look at the problem
from multiple angles to understand
all the ways in which it could be viewed
the more holistically you view a problem
the more paths you look at the more
efficient and effective you're going to
be at solving it
[Music]
one of these is most interesting to me
is the field of robotics
and the different ways machine learning
will impact our society so robotics
combines lots of maths lots of science
lots of technology but also
socio-economic factors such as human and
robot trust so how humans feel about
robots how they trust them and human
robot teams in the workplace so how
humans and robots work together to
accomplish a task
and creativity will be hugely important
here so creativity is not only going to
be important in designing the robots
they're very intricate very complex
systems and will require creativity to
know exactly how to design them to do
their jobs
but also how to integrate them into our
everyday lives which is a total
different facet of creativity and it's
actually a new way of thinking because
it hasn't really been done yet so even
though there are robots around us and
we've seen we've seen them you've got
the roomba who's hoover's your living
room
really where we're heading is for robots
to be everywhere and to be a really
integral part of our society so
preparing for that change and using
creativity to figure out the best way to
do that will be a really important step
in innovation in the future
[Music]